I mean clearly we felt as if it was our
productive and unfortunately all the
work that was put in over the past two
weeks the media is going to overshadow
it by that negativity that we see in
violence we don't condone violence but
we also understand and know that our
young boys who are out here who are
causing the violence they're really
speaking in frustration unfortunately
they've been failed from a
socio-economic perspective they've been
failed from a school in perspective they
live in basic abject poverty and that's
their tone and that's their message they
don't have the ability of going in front
of a TV camera and intellectually
expelling that frustration out to you
and the way that they're doing it is
violence again I'm not condoning it I'm
not saying it's acceptable and we needed
to cease immediately however I think
it's critically important that once we
bring a calm the Baltimore we understand
and know that we need to reach out to
the young and we need to provide them
with real opportunities and a real
chance to truly succeed in America you
talk about people speaking out in
frustration do you mean frustration over
the death of Freddie gray or do you
think it's a bigger issue than that this
is much bigger than Freddie gray Freddie
gray was the last incident that kind of
culminated what's going on however it
provided them with the opportunity to
truly speak out about it the one thing
I'll say is 90% of all of the protesting
demonstrations have been truly peaceful
and unfortunately the media is going to
cover the 10% it's going to see it's
going to overshadow all the positives
that put in work another thing is you
know the guys around me the 300 men
movement are led by men in Bihar and
Brandon Scott had been out here for
years really reaching out to the
community engaging these young folks
trying to bring a common divide that's
been broken in our community between
police enforcement and the community for
some years and you know all that has
played out over the past couple of weeks
truly increases that divide and truce it
truly increases that distrust when you
hear this is the type of stuff that
we're not showing in America we're not
showing you know how these are men men
in Baltimore City the 300 men moving
again is out in front and truly trying
to take back the streets trying to
engage the young boys and try to ensure
that folks understand and know that we
can we understand the frustration well
yes and how would you characterize the
level of anger there over Freddie gray
but also over other people Michael Brown
Eric garner Trayvon Martin over race and
policing and perceived prejudice how
would you characterize that and where do
you think it could lead the level of
anger is high it's very tense there was
just a conflict literally about 15 or 20
minutes ago when the corner of Fulton in
North Avenue here in West Baltimore see
people keep comparing this to Ferguson
but Baltimore is not Ferguson
you know Baltimore's blocks and blocks
and blocks of alleys and street ways and
abandoned buildings you know this is not
a Midwest City small town this is a
major American city with a scale and the
scope of individuals that I just really
are disgusted at the current living
conditions in the current status
unfortunately they're fighting their
grandfather's battle you know this
poverty does lack of education is lack
of resources there's this pipeline of
prison that has been recycling these
individuals over and over again it's
nothing new to this generation we
understand and know that change comes
from the youth and unfortunately the you
for speaking in a violent way in a way
that's unproductive and that's why I'm
in like 300 men are trying to get to
them however you know they're speaking
you know again they don't have the
ability of going in front of a camera
and intellectually telling you why
they're so frustrated the systemic
issues that plagued communities that
they live in however they're showing us
they're showing up their pain you know
we had the ability to stop it some folks
who are affiliated with a gang here in
Baltimore they have been drinking all
day they've been unproductive all day
and towards the end of the night one of
them just completely broke down because
they're tired everybody wants to be
productive when we're born no matter if
you're in the UK or in America your
parents and your folks tell you that you
could be whatever you want to be in life
but unfortunately that's not always true
for folks depending on their zip code
and area code and folks are frustrated
and upset again I will continue to
stress we don't condone it we don't we
know it's unproductive we know it's not
bringing us closer to justice however
I'm just trying to explain the plight
and try to explain the mentalities young
boys that are going out here committing
to violence
well yes and fires have been later those
shops were looted last night in the
pete'll Pett pelted with bottles and
bricks and other debris as well do you
think the police should have been
tougher on those protesters I think the
police I mean I don't think they
expected to see what they got
I think they've divided they decided to
prepare for the young children of
Baltimore I was going to meet up at
mondawmin and start this purge movement
they met there with 50 to 70 officers
and some armored vehicles they pushed
the kids into the community to a main
thoroughfare that runs east and west
through Baltimore called North Avenue
and it's at that point that's when it
erupted I was in the middle of it I was
driving in my car from the the from the
funeral side of new Shiloh to City Hall
about 4:40 yesterday when I seen the
first police car get brutally attacked
by a mob of probably 20 to 30 40 kids
and those pockets continued to spread
throughout the night and you know at the
end of the day the most important step
is for us to defuse the situation
de-escalate it meet them to a point
where understanding no we have to
enforce the laws so if you're breaking
the law you need to face the
consequences but we need to develop a
way deescalate this and we need the
subject matter expertise here I'm glad
that local jurisdictions have come on
board I'm glad that the Maryland Guard
has come on board but we really need to
bring calm to our communities okay well
Nick Mosby we appreciate you talking to
us here tonight at Baltimore City
Councilman Nick Mosby thank you thank
you so much